dana roarock will try to finish up on a
real positive note here with his final
start of the season it'll be his 11th
start the blue jays are not locked into
the eight seat a lot of people think
they're better off in the eight than the
five
but they are not locked into the eighth
seed if they win and the yankees lose
the blue jays will be the five seed and
rower gets one out on one pitch getting
austin hayes it has gone single single
and now free pass they are loaded up for
rio ruiz the one two
and a very frustrated ruiz
two down
and a ground ball to third biggio to the
bag wins the race let's take a look at
keegan akins numbers this season
his eighth game his sixth start of the
year
two balls no strikes that's hit hard
into right field
and a nice running catch back there well
done by stuart
one down wow is that a beauty
dj stewart's had his problems in the
outfield this year good job
here perfect aiken looking into cisco
now ready 2-2 pitch on the way got him
that's
that one wasn't a strike we're going
home boarding right not telling you
that's a dart right there 94 miles an
hour beyond first two down
got him
sometimes you might be better off as a
lower seed if you know who you're going
to play as a team you might have a
better shot against good curveball there
by rohar to get him
back into the ymca one a curveball hit
high in the air down the right field
line to the corner jonathan davis is on
the run and that ball is
leaping at the wall and davis caught it
are you kidding me
jonathan davis soaring through the air
right next to the pole makes a leaping
grab
wow was that ever something
a highlight reel of highlight reel
catches
everybody in uniform waiting on jonathan
davis as he jogs in from right field
giving him high fives and
congratulations with a spectacular catch
and they are looking to take the lead at
the bottom of the second no score right
now a remarkable sensational catch by
jonathan davis who's at the plate right
now
and now he drives the ball to right
field
and it'll be deep enough to get a run
home stewart the catch guriel can tag
i i don't know what he was doing but he
eventually comes in to score he maybe
didn't know how many outs there were
yeah i don't know who you'd want to face
really the the rays of the white sox
both pretty dangerous right now
that's it well deep center field grechik
racing back
he was way off on his
trip to that ball
he went straight back and the ball was
way to his right he just he must not
have picked it up off the bat the blue
jays are coming up tied one run a piece
with the orioles today
vladimir guerrero jr jumps on a fastball
and he drives it deep center field and
go on
an absolute rocket
over the wall in straight away center
field for vladimir guerrero jr it's his
ninth home run of the season blue jays
back on top 2-1 lourdes with a double
his first time up he needs another hit
to get to 300.
and he wallops one down the left field
line as long as it's fair it's gone and
it is
what a shot by goriel and it is four to
one
it is a two-hit day a 300 average for
lourdes gorilla jr with third and leica
at first blue jays lead at 4-1 that's it
well
center field grijit racing back won't
get it it's up against the wall
alberto scores gaining the green light
is valleca
the throw to third and mullins is in
with a two-run triple
three-two breaking ball it's hit well
let's see if this will get mullins home
curiel with the catch here comes the
throw
and mullins is in
because we're down four to one got three
in the third inning
in the fourth inning in our threatening
here in the fifth
that's hit hard down the right field
line that's a fair ball into the corner
mount castle around third he scores
and ruiz has a double in the orioles
with three straight hits here to start
the fifth inning typically run into the
manager uh maybe throughout the day but
they always have contact with their
coaches bounce to short that'll get a
run home
alberto out at first but nunez scores
and the orioles lead at 6-4
the pitch on the way he swings lashes it
into center field base hit one more
comes on down from third base this time
it's rio ruiz and their lead is seven of
four on the blue jig
bieber's got a 163 era he's got 122
strikeouts in 77 innings
brown bow to second and safe on the play
as it popped out of mount castle's glove
guri ellen to score and it's 7-5
2-0 pitch
bounced up the middle alberta has it and
the orioles
put one in the win column
so the final out and the birds win it
7-5 some handshakes